foreign
[Music]
what's the biggest misconception would
you say a of pro wrestling
well I think if you want to get into pro
wrestling you have to have a great
imagination I think that you as a kid
you you had to pretend that you were you
know I used to when I was younger I used
this is crazy but
I would pretend that Russia was spying
on me because I was such a superior
athlete and they were watching me play
basketball and watch me play football
and I like I had this imagination of you
know that I was this incredible athlete
that everybody in the world was you know
searching for yeah Wayne's you know I
was the next big thing yeah you know so
um having the imagination and being a
great athlete and intertwining those can
really help you in the wlb in sports
entertainment you also has to have some
acting skills too yeah you I mean you it
comes you know it comes with experience
you're gonna they didn't teach me how to
do that stuff they they just said hey
you're you know we don't have they
didn't have a program back then for it
they had this Dojo where they Dory Funk
Dojo where they taught you how to
wrestle and they did a little bit on
promise but it wasn't it wasn't a lot
now they have a NXT which is a training
facility they do promos they teach you
acting skills they teach you wrestling
everything back then they didn't have it
so when I started Vince said sink or
swim here's your promo he actually the
first night he read it to me he said
you're going to say it and I said Vince
I didn't hear a word you said I'm a
little nervous right now he goes I'm
going to tell you one more time if you
don't say it you sink
so he told me one more time and he said
now go out and do it and I did it and
that's when he said I have somebody that
somebody special and what did you find
in me the the bad like the performance
aspect of it did that bring you towards
it or did it push like I I love that
yeah I love that because you're [__]
great at it right and yeah yeah it was
it was I didn't think I'd pick up that
quickly I uh you know from when I
started the first day I wrestled or I
learned taking bumps I guess uh two days
later I had my first match that's
impossible that you know that was I was
very I picked up very quickly on the
technique but I they started me on TV
literally seven months later they
usually have to be about three to five
years in before you start on TV uh seven
months in and I won the world title yeah
ten months after that is it yeah isn't
this a 20-year anniversary of you yeah
yeah yeah so uh the thing is I I didn't
know what I was doing but Dwayne the
Rock uh called the whole match in there
he just told me where to go what to do
so here I am I'm going to be the
champion of WWE and I don't even know
how to work yeah right so
um but Vince I I wasn't screwing up I
was getting better and better and better
the more I performed the more better I
got the more promos I did the better I
got and by the time I won the world
title there was no looking back yeah
yeah and then be being a great follower
made me a great leader and I learned how
to work myself and improvise and before
I knew it my next opponent was Stone
Cold Steve Austin I beat him for the
title yeah so the two biggest you know
two most popular support superstars in
history were my first two titles wow and
uh it was a blessing because they taught
me so much that I became a great worker
after that and I started leading the
patches yeah yeah have you seen the
state of of sort of the fans has it
changed because I remember as a kid I
used to go all the time and I remember
you know like my old man used to take me
and Dougie when we were kids and I mean
like I mean that it was like vulgar back
then man I mean people were like
throwing bottles
I mean the things that people were
saying I remember being like you know
first time like being really scared like
you know what I mean of of the audience
right but you know I I don't want to see
you a few times and you know man I was
actually really surprised with how civil
it's it's very much they had to change
it and a lot of it had to do with um WWE
becoming a publicly traded company
um uh once they did that the the
shareholders decided
how do we make the most money
kits how do we get kids there parents
how do we get the parents there Market
to the kids so everything merchandise uh
everything they do
um everything's PG rated now yeah if not
even G-rated yeah you can't swear you
can't you can't say anything uh that
isn't approved so they they they're
making more money now and I'm not gonna
say they have a bigger fan base yeah
they do worldwide but in the United
States The Attitude Era was pretty much
yeah you know the main era where we were
selling out every single night do you
think it would have been easier for you
to play a heel or or or like a hit like
a good guy
well I think uh starting out the the
problem with wrestling is pro wrestling
is
in order to be a baby face it'd be a big
baby fish you have to be a heel first
the fans won't accept you until you go
through the process yeah earning your
keep before you go so
whether you like it or not you have to
do it yeah um I enjoyed it I like people
pissing people off I thought it was fun
yeah you know
um and you know I you know every once
while I get something thrown at me or
you know you know it was back then it
was still a little rough yeah but I it
was cool I mean I I just really enjoyed
uh pissing off the fans and and having
that reaction because I knew that the
more popular I became as a heel the more
popular I would be as an overall
wrestler so Roddy Piper didn't become
the biggest baby face in wrestling good
guy uh because you know he just showed
up he did it because he earned it he all
those years he was healed these fans you
know not only did they [__] on him but
they were like this guy this guy's
entertainment he's entertaining he's
really funny There's Something about
making people hate you I mean I remember
when I did Shane on The Walking Dead
yeah you know like I had never had any
experience experience like that I
remember we went to like you know New
York Comic-Con and the show hadn't even
come out yet
and you know like Andrew Lincoln that
was a good heel part by the way it was
so much fun man and and I but I didn't
even like to me and I'm such a douchebag
actor I'm like I'm just playing the
Integrity of you know he's a great guy I
feel like he's like yeah I feel great
you know what I mean like I feel like he
made the right choices according to him
like I believe in everything that I'm
doing and like I remember at New York
Comic-Con you know room of thousands you
know was like walking dead this big
comic book and Andrew Lincoln comes up
and he goes hello I'm Andrew Lincoln and
I'm gonna be playing Rick Ross and then
like Sarah Wayne College yeah I'm gonna
play and they went like one by one and
then I came to me and I'm like hello
everybody I'm John bernth I'll be
playing Shane Walsh and I was like ready
for and it was like this resounding like
I remember I I was like oh you know like
me
yeah I was like what is this man like
you haven't even seen the show like like
you know what I mean and I'm like you
and it was uh it was I never I never
felt that before I mean you've been like
to have a uh thousands of people
especially when you're not expecting I
was like how could you
applaud for her and not a not like what
an audience and they've read the comic
books and they hate they hated that
character so Shane was always the heel
he was always a human and I fought and
but the one thing that I will say that's
that's interesting about it that that
goes along right with what you're saying
is by the next year once the show had
already come out you know and then Shane
had actually done some bad you know he
like killed he killed you know fat Otis
and he killed you know he'd done some
pretty shady [__] yeah at that year when
they announced it they all were like
yeah yeah
man they're like you might be shitty but
you are [__] you know we accepted you
yeah dude like you did it all right man
and and that like you know man that that
uh that definitely that definitely made
me happy and what about like um you know
obviously you know the the injuries that
you yeah that's what I'm wondering is
how I mean it's got to be so hard on
your body to just sustain yeah all those
shots over the years over years over
years yeah I I you know amateur
wrestling is one of the most
injury-prone sports and I got injured a
lot doing it but um getting into pro
wrestling I didn't realize the wear and
tear put on your body I I thought it was
fake I thought you know
all the stuff you know you're pulling
punches you weren't really uh doing
anything but you know when I got there
and I took the bumps you ever been in
the ring and take a bump
you have to be a supreme athlete right
yeah well it's just it hurts it's the
worst pain
um you never get you ever get hit from
behind going 50. yeah that's pretty much
what it is wow so you have every every
night too every night you're bumping
yeah and this is what I tell young
wrestlers that they want to be they'll
be Superstars someday which is great
um limit your box
[Music]
foreign
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and uh again grateful that you guys tune
in we've decided we want to take things
just a step further it's a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become part of this community
look I already board Bam Bam if you want
to become a part of this community
you're going to be able to hear episodes
early and all that ad free and all that
good stuff but there's all this behind
the scenes footage all this stuff that
we've shot that really brings you into
the folks that we've had on the show
really brings you into their world live
chats with me and the folks that I bring
on the show to talk about their world
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll